I need to know what it is what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] she looks like she's
[ __ ] 12 8 maybe and she we're gonna
give her a circumcision is that what
it's called
now wait that's what we're gonna give
her as serein birth I was serene birth
so this might be educational for me kids
play this game this is a kid's website
more I'm just I'm even scared of
clicking that [ __ ] button thankfully
it doesn't go anyway all right just look
at the [ __ ] picture
we know this game is a horror game and
why is she wearing a princess crap what
kind of [ __ ] person goes into a
surion birth and where's the [ __ ]
tiara oh my god why did I find this
alright we need to sterilize our cotton
and rub it so we're here I don't I'm
trying I like that we have a pulse meter
that means she can die in the [ __ ]
that's great I can have a [ __ ]
stillborn in this game that'd be just
alright and then we use the drugs oh god
oh god this [ __ ] gay man what
happened to my oh oh sorry I just got
some pretty puke going on alright well
that was nice kids needs to learn this
fresh clip get a clerk in case your mom
ever don't want to go a goddamn blood
too much blood I can't get the blood out
of there what the [ __ ] ah [ __ ]
dice like more oh god I did not need to
see that what the [ __ ] what is it oh god
what the [ __ ]
ah so much blood buddy how is a kids
game oh my God he's coming out of her
what is that is that a penis 10 alien
say demon son Ebola naughty
oh god my hands drag it gooder Oh God Oh
God ah I pull that baby [ __ ] ouch huh
Oh for [ __ ] sake what do I have to do
now shake that [ __ ] to the side I need
to click there up a [ __ ] band-aid a
band-aid
a band-aid who thought this was a good
idea
I can't what did all right
there's another game that I think we
should explore God they have Angry Birds
where's my water
they have motorcycle and they have
babies second out at 80 it's only
natural so it's taking a [ __ ] but I'm
saying am I gonna make a game out of
that actually there's probably plenty of
games send them to me please give a
birth to your daughter well be shame to
give a birth to someone else's [ __ ]
daughter wouldn't it
what say if I click I hear some sucking
noises great detail I love a game that
pays attention to detail especially all
these [ __ ] glimmers and [ __ ] that's
how you know a game is legit if you're
making a game and you forgot about those
glimmery shits like just quit your job
and get into [ __ ] retailing or some
[ __ ] [ __ ] I don't know doctor I'm in
pain she didn't actually say it she just
thought it in a pink [ __ ] cloud while
looking constipated and she's not saying
any though apparently if you're pregnant
with a doctor you can use telekinesis no
wait tell it pathy whatever don't worry
let me see your vagina
alright here's my hand I will see you
with my hand cuz that's how doctors see
when they just see through their hands I
shall put my hand there as well and here
as well you will give a birth you will
give up birth to your daughter today she
did that with her head it's just some
kind of [ __ ] witch doctor next one at
last I have been waiting this for nine
months and the cloud is coming from her
belly so I assume that's the baby that
said that every which makes sense of
course don't forget how to breathe when
you feel contractions
okay keep that in mind she forgot how to
breathe so we are teaching her how to do
it and try to move more it will ease the
contractions who made this
what's up never mind alright move more
let's yes of course this this felt
appropriate right now well done what an
amazing effort
what a [ __ ] champ I'm pretty much
qualified to me give birth to a baby now
even as a man I feel like I could do
that [ __ ] now cuz let's be on it okay
doctor the contractions are too
difficult to bear
so she teleport into the bed well that's
his [ __ ] grain a special massage will
help okay hope you like my Swedish
[ __ ] massage the power of the thumbs
shall let your humps be guns that was
the best rap I ever made Barbara let's
see how would go so the [ __ ] is Barbara
all the sudden Oh God
well we knew this was coming spread your
legs for me well that was easy
that was a lot easier than that [ __ ] I
did before I wish okay and yeah there
you go suck on those titties
Oh God that is an ugly baby it's it too
late for an abortion I don't even want
to know what the [ __ ] these two games
are but I'm gonna go and probably cry in
the shower a little bit I hope you boys
enjoyed this video if you did hit that
like button let me know if you wanted me
to do more of these and I'll see you
next one as always
[Music]